hallo leute heute ist ein echter
scheißtag ich bin krank und es regnet
aber zum glück haben wir wohl ort geht
heute mechanisch raus und er wird leute
nach dem weg fragen wollt wohin gehst du
ich gehe zum alexanderplatz das fragt
wollt jetzt unter anderem auf der straße
und diese folge ist dem thema richtungen
gewidmet viel spaß
können sie können sie mir sagen wie
komme ich von hier zum rosenthaler platz
einfach hier die straße
ok also endlich annehmen oder einfach
die straße ja okay danke
sie möchten zum großen teil der platz an
das richtig verstanden
ok dann steigen sie hier in die nächste
straßenbahn ein ist egal welche die
steigen wir die straßenbahn ein und
fahren
das wird angesagte gibt es also gibt es
info und es heißt dann rosenthaler platz
und dann steigen sie aus am rosenthaler
platz und da ist auch die rosendahler
straße
können sie mir sorgen
wie komme ich von hier zu großen teilen
platz mit der bank oder mit der bahn
hier können wir die in die wahl
einsteigen und dann drei vier stationen
onkel und beifuß geradeaus immer
geradeaus eigentlich dankeschön
wir sind nichts von dir wir sind
amerikanerin
wo sind alle pflanzen jahr besser sie
kommen aus steglitz und ihren garten an
dankeschön tschüss am rosenthaler platz
da gehen sie einmal hier so dankeschön
ganz einfach zu fuß runter laufen so
denke schon dass ich den weg dahin
die wird er ja das ist kein witz
wie viele minuten sieben minuten glich
schnell sein leicht auch einfach
geradeaus laufen gerade aus
wie lange muss ich schlafen gemütlich 77
runter laufen und wie lange muss ich
kaufen stunde entschuldigung gibt es
hier in die nähe eine sparkasse gibt es
hier in den eher eine sparkasse
sparkasse sparkasse andere richtung in
diese richtung diese marke ja wie komme
ich von hier zum alexanderplatz mit der
u bahn oder der u2 okay du nimmst
einfach von der eberswalder die u2 und
fenstern zu 2
wie lange dauert das ganz einfach hier
rauf gehen dann die u bahn nehmen und
drei stationen fahren
bitteschön zurück zur o2 die da oben
fährt und die dann ein paar station
nehmen so unterlaufen immer geradeaus
grad aus gras drauf gehen und dann im
westen
links ok und wie spät ist es viertel vor
sechs dankeschön also einmal hier unter
den weg bis zur u bahn haltestelle und
dann die u bahn richtung olympiastadion
nehmen und dann einfach am alex
aussteigen und wie spät ist es habe ich
auf die uhr gucken 17 uhr 47 dankeschön
fährt alle fünf minuten also ich denke
mal sie kommen an alexanderplatz preview
2 neben drei stationen ok und wie spät
ist es spät es ist ja jetzt 17 48 uhr 2
wie spät ist es
ich weiß es nicht es ist jetzt fünf vor
sechs junge leute das war unsere heutige
episode mit wild wald wo kommst du
eigentlich her
ich komme aus den usa und was machst du
in berlin
ich mache einen deutschkurs sehr gut da
hat mir das ja vielleicht heute geholfen
wie war es denn auf der straße es war
eine gute übung special das heißt du
kannst jetzt leute nach dem weg fragen
ja genau perfekt und ihr liebe leute
euch fragen wir demnächst auch nach den
weg denn heute ist sonntag wenn dieses
video erscheint und morgen ist folglich
montag und an diesem montag den 10
oktober fahren wir mit unserem team
endlich in die usa im rolls heimat und
wollen dort schulen besuchen
universitäten besucher und menschen
treffen die easy german schauen und
deutschland wo kommst du in den usa her
aus welchem bundesland von kalifornien
aus kalifornien dafür zum beispiel auch
in wir starten in new york dann nach
washington sie dann nach colorado
colorado springs man einen roadtrip
durch monument valley über las vegas
nach los angeles san francisco und
zurück nach los angeles das ist unser
plan für den nächsten vier wochen
und wenn ihr das jetzt seht solltet ihr
unbedingt uns folgen wenn wir werden
jeden tag also eigentlich jeden tag
etwas posten bei youtube also hier aber
auch bei facebook und bei instagram
deshalb müsst ihr sicher gehen dass ihr
uns folgt damit ihr alle updates bekommt
schaut mal hier unten in unserer infobox
haben wir alle links unbedingt facebook
instagram folgen
danke fürs zuschauen abonniert unseren
kanal danke dir dass du dabei warst und
bis bald in den usa